so we have a very busy man on our hands
today's Tom beric he of course its
founder of colony capital and now it's
colony Northstar he's the executive
chair there but more important this week
at least he's the chair of the
presidential inauguration committee so
thank you very much for taking time out
Tom to be with us today thanks for
having me David so you got started last
night with your first official event and
it was a striking event for who was
invited and where it was tell us about
that dinner last night so the the
president-elect who's the greatest
celebrity in the world by the way he did
such an amazing job when when he set out
this week wanted the first chapter to be
a little bit about his sensitivity and
his interest in foreign policy so he
said what do we do for foreign diplomats
and I said well actually there's not
much that's ever done for foreign
diplomats and he said well I want that
to be my first fingerprint on the global
canvass I want to introduce to them with
my cultural six senses and attribute to
the domestic foreign diplomatic course
so he picked a venue which was pretty
amazing that the the Mellon building was
actually the site in 1949 a where NATO
was signed so that's where NATO
originated it down in Constitution
Avenue absolutely at a time much
different than the Marshall Plan and the
dismay around the world and of course
after the war both Europe and Japan were
in dismay so those 12 nations came
together in that place to create a
different kind of tapestry in 1949 so
the idea was let's make this at the
beginning of weaving those long lines of
all of our nation partners to create
this new global tapestry so it's
fascinating we started with diplomats
and with the site where NATO assigned
just three or four days after he gave an
interview to The Wall Street Journal
saying NATO was obsolete and when you
known Donald Trump for a good long time
we all are eager to find out what he is
as president how do we interpret these
signals that seem to be contradictory
and people are having a tough time
sorting through yes it's a great
question and the answer is the switch
from candidate to president so the sound
bites which are brilliantly displayed in
144 characters
and he can communicate instantly to the
world in 144 characters now have to be
gauged with some precision so when he
talks about NATO being obsolete he's not
saying get rid of NATO he's saying you
had a treaty an agreement that was cast
really based on foreign policy not based
on economics we had to bring Europe back
to security back to relevance in 1949 so
now what he's saying is don't worry I'm
not saying we don't want to have
alliances with Europe I'm saying what we
have to do is now put the varnish on top
of the furniture the furniture was
beautiful created a long time ago but it
needs something else and we need to redo
it so just think of it you just think of
technology in 1949 to send a cable if
you were a foreigner for approval would
take three weeks now you tweet no it's
there anything around the world in an
instant at the same time I mean he is
taking some positions I wonder whether
the the presidential Donald Trump
understands it has to be different from
the candidate and the transitional job
because now not only NATO over the
weekend he gave interviews with European
news but was really going after Angela
Merkel the head of Germany and
suggesting maybe the EU would largely
dissolve I mean this Donald Trump
understand he has to change the way he
communicates I don't I don't think he's
viewing the world is having to change
how he communicates what he has to do is
now have a platform which he hasn't had
he's the president-elect his team is not
yet there which is disappointing right
you would hope that Congress would say
let's get his team in place but to be
America and then let let him play this
out with people like Rex Tillerson
and general mattis and Mike Flynn and
katie mcfarland and his team team is
beyond experienced so what you're gonna
see is the president play out these
chapters with much more lucidity than
people think he's not careless he's not
corrupt he's very thoughtful but by the
way saying that
that Europe is threatened is not a new
thought of course Europe is threatened
economically and they need our help and
everybody needs to focus so you're going
to see much more depth but he's not yet
president so I tell everybody give him a
chance let him get his team in place Rex
Tillerson there is no better Secretary
of State in my humble opinion that could
have been picked he understands the
hardware he understands in the world
that team that foreign policy team will
be epic however the president will draw
hard lines where they need to be drawn
and he will stick with them and once
again trying to help us understand this
new president how to untie say we have
Rex Tillerson today we've got Wilbur
Ross is up for confirmation
his hearings begin just today should we
increase them going to listen to the
rectal oceans of this world the Wilbur
Ross's this world the Steve minuchin
this world will Donald Trump himself
take a step back in his communication
and let some of his cabinet officers
speak for him yeah I mean I think what
you're gonna do is see Donald Trump take
a step forward and saying look I'll help
you create the architecture of a vision
and the structure which by the way the
535 congressional and senatorial
partners will help write that we don't
have a dictatorship so the the Vice
president-elect is one of the best
conciliators known to mankind so this
partnership of saying what is doable
what is practical what is needed what is
my economic plan for the first hundred
days will be specific and he will adela
gate responsibility and accountability
to his team a hundred percent he is
first and foremost a businessman that's
that's how he came to his position
what are his expectations for success in
that first hundred days how will he
measure himself we all have to have
metrics in order to manage how will he
manage him how will he measure himself
well look my opinion just as a friend
you have to ask him how and they measure
himself but he's a Lock and Load person
he doesn't confuse efforts with results
so he sits down and has a yellow pad and
says these are the things that I'm going
to accomplish in partnership with a
congressional environment that has to
has to come on side knowing that all
that what he has to do is when
constituencies who are doubtful so he
realizes that just like the foreign
expectations but the man is brilliant so
what he did last night the the the
foreign community had no idea who this
man is I can tell you for sure
last night the cables were flying saying
this president-elect is so much better
so much more thoughtful so much more
culturally adapt that anybody thought
and as the first president in recent
history who's reached out in that way is
a tribute to his foreign policy it's
brilliant it's a very soft sensitive
move you're gonna see that across every
level and then you're gonna see Rex
Tillerson and a Wilbur Ross and Steve
minuchin and Michael Flynn and every one
of the secretary designate Tom Price is
taking heat
well everybody takes heat in the
transition process when that microscope
goes on every tiny detail of what your
life has been and and all these men and
women have been living a life that
wasn't based on saying I'm gonna go into
a political structure at some point in
time these are all Outsiders that have
been using the hardware and there's not
inappropriateness it's under that
microscope everything is examined with a
different light they are going to be the
most formidable group of people to come
to Washington because they have to work
that bureaucracy and that's where the
frustration lies is you can have a great
vision you can have a great idea and
then you come to Washington and they
smile and say oh yeah you want to see
how quickly yeah that's right but first
you have an oration to put hot so good
luck with Friday you have a very busy
few days it's really good for you spend
time this is Tom Barrett